so we have to start today digging
further into the supposed coved relief
bill a so-called rescue package for
i guess it's supposed to be for
americans even though
it's really apparently for corporations
and rich people and this has now been
approved
by congress and this may be one of the
biggest scams of 2020 and there have
been many scams in 2020. the trump
campaign was a scam
trump's handling of covid was a massive
scam and failure
trump's continued claims of things like
it's the flu 15 cases will go to zero
that's a massive scam
trump's campaign fundraising to launder
money through a shell company to his
family it's a scam
trump fundraising after the election
claiming the money will help him
overturn the results
when it's really going 50 to help him
pay off his campaign debt
it's scam after scam this is the year of
scams
but this covet rescue package is a major
scam now as i told you yesterday it's a
900 billion dollar
total package it's part of a bigger
package that includes 1.4 trillion for
funding government
so you wrap a bunch of stuff not related
to covid
into the relief bill and then connect it
to the spending bill it's not super
clear why but that's not necessarily a
problem
but then you see the details for people
not corporations just normal people
making up to 75
000 a year they get six hundred dollars
per adult
you get an extra three hundred dollars
per week of unemployment
if you are out of a job altogether and
on state unemployment for eleven months
money might start going out as soon as
next week maybe last time it took months
and months so we'll see
but the real story here is the pathetic
nature of
how money for people compares to money
for everything else including
corporations after remember
seven months of nothing being done
so let's go through it i mentioned that
combining the 1.4 trillion dollar bill
to fund government with the 900 billion
covid relief is not necessarily a
problem and it's not
necessarily a problem except here it is
a problem because
in total the two things together are
more than 5 500 pages
and the vote took place last night just
a few hours after the full text was
released
again ensuring that no member of
congress could actually see what they
were voting for
this is a common scam in our government
it happens all the time and one of the
things that was stuck into the bill
is that it would make it illegal it
would make it a felony
to illegally stream video as an example
as well as a bunch of other
pro-corporate handouts in terms of
intellectual property
and congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez pointed this out
and explained this is an example of what
they didn't have time to read
tweeting quote this is why congress
needs time to actually read this package
before voting on it
members of congress have not read this
bill it's over 5000
pages arrived at 2pm today and we are
told to expect a vote in two hours this
isn't governance
it's hostage taking and she's correct
the bill has a handout of 120 billion
to rich business owners and other
provisions that are great for the
wealthy
there's a provision that businesses that
get ppp loans
can not only have the loans forgiven
meaning it's free money
but they can also deduct the loan amount
spent on business expenses against their
taxable income so
you get a million dollar ppp loan as an
example you don't have to pay it back so
it's really a gift of a million dollars
but then also the stuff you spend the
money on from the loan which was free
you deduct from your taxes and it lowers
your taxable income i mean it's truly
wild and meanwhile
some people will get six hundred dollars
now
uh uh i i there's this other provision
about
increasing the deductibility of meals
from 50
to 100 some people are mad about this as
well
i've dealt with this before like if i go
to a conference for a week and i spend a
few hundred dollars on meals during the
conference or
i take the team out for dinner if you
can imagine that i mean you know it's
covered but
at the time when we did if i spend 100
bucks on meals
for the team i can only deduct 50 of it
only 50 of it essentially is a tax
deductible expense
they want to up that to a hundred they
have up that to a hundred percent
i like it and then it benefits me this
is the only thing that i get
and this is an opportunity for me to to
mention again people
keep emailing me saying david you greedy
bastard
you want more money for yourself you
want twelve hundred dollars instead of
six hundred again
i'm getting nothing i qualify for
nothing
i would benefit from the hundred percent
deductibility of meals as a business
expense if there's ever a thing as a
business meal again
okay but i'm we've taken no ppp money
uh i get no money personally i have no
kids that they get money i
i get nothing okay i'm thinking about
other people
um so this is way bigger than any one
thing is the point and part of this
is that lots of democrats are fine with
all this stuff just like republicans
some are not like aoc but she still
voted for it because
600 is better than nothing and she was
given two hours to read
5500 pages part of this is that
there simply isn't even time to know
what's in the bill as i mentioned
and then part of this is that at a
systemic level
how do you go seven months with nothing
and then offer six hundred dollars
while giving huge corporations tons of
goodies and handouts
it's quite frankly infuriating this is
what we have now
let's see what happens after january
20th
with a different president and we don't
yet know
maybe a different party controlling the
senate and again
those georgia races are very much in
focus
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water
for rehydration and they're giving you
25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
percent off your first order when you go
to drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video